oui
[Musique]
et
mais
à moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
à
à moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh bien bon soir bonsoir à tous et
bienvenue pour ce mardi 21 avril
2020 on est pour le diagonal torride
spirits blitz donc arena on est
20h13 pour un tournoi qui va demeurer à
mettre 30
alors on est 45 joueurs avant le début
ce qui est un très bon score la semaine
dernière on avait fait 79 ce qui était
très bien je pense que c'est bien quand
on est dans ces eaux là je pense que
plus de plus de 40 plus de 50 c'est bien
on fait des tournois sympa on peut
rencontrer plusieurs fois un même joueur
mais pas trop une deux ou trois fois
maximum
il reste encore beaucoup de temps mais
sur avant le avant la fin et peut-être
battre le record la semaine dernière
alors déjà 45 c'est le deuxième meilleur
score en déjà avant le début du tournoi
ce que l'autre meilleur score était à 35
je crois après 79
alors donc alors des petites nouvelles
alors des petites nouvelles en d'abord
oui cette semaine je diffuse donc sur
une mine aux échecs donc comme je
voulais dire si vous voulez être au
courant de tous les stream il vaut mieux
vous abonner aux deux chaînes
youtube imineo échec et la chaîne
diagonale tv ce qui élimine aux échecs
c'est quand même la chaîne historique ou
diagonales tv a été diffusé en ligne
et ça le restera sept cd priori ça
restera quand même là pendant quelques
temps
et pas de raison que ça change et la
chaîne diagonale tv c'est une chaîne
plus spécifiques et plus alimentée de
manière un peu plus récentes
voilà donc donc logis suis sûr les deux
et donc ça m'arrive de retourner sur le
minot échec et cette semaine je vais
faire aussi sans doute un string demain
donc je ferai au moins deux cette
semaine sur imineo échec voilà donc ça
c'est pour ceux qui se demandent
pourquoi c'est pas sur la même voie là
ça c'est comme ça c'est dit alors on est
on est sur un très bon niveau de
tournois puisqu'on a king ou babar donc
est un habitué
en fait quels joueurs on peut le dire
puisqu'il a joué pour perpignan les rois
de la tête dans un grand match
interclubs donc il est de perpignan n'en
dit pas plus parce que je garde le
suspense en deux on a ce qu'il clame
2356 en 3e et fournit à 2354 en quatre
ans à monticello d'obea 2314 bref c'est
du très bon niveau et
on arrive aussi alors pour les joueurs
en bas de tournois pour l'instant on a
des joueurs des débutants aussi sans
doute qui voilà qui sont là qui sont
courageux qui vont jouer
donc je vous invite bien sûr si vous
m'écoutez que vous débutez même si vous
avez un petit niveau et jouer c'est pas
grave hein si vous allez perdre est
parti mais vous aurez des chances de
jouer contre des joueurs de votre niveau
aussi
ah bon et donc 1929 1274 1277
voyant napoléon lepreau qui a mis 500
points d'interrogation ça on sait pas
trop quel est son niveau quand ya un
point d'interrogation sur leach s ça
peut être un joueur très fort on sait
pas du tout puisqu'il faut attendre
vingt parties pour que l'it chaise ou
peut-être même 30 je sais plus
exactement pour que l'it chaise vous
donne un classement à peu près stable
donc tant qu'il ya un problème
dérogation c'est pas qu'elle l'ait
niveau du joueur
c'est sans doute quelqu'un qui viennent
s'inscrire en fait puisque on démarre je
crois qu'on est marrant 1500 si je me
rappelle bien fait leur truc 77 à ces
kifer 2,77 pas ce que fait leur trou si
bien sûr on grand maître très très connu
est-ce que ça serait peut-être de sa
famille peut être un petit fait dans
tout cas je sais pas
oué
peut-être tout simplement un fan voilà
il y avait 66 cayla et quel joueur qui a
progressé beaucoup
depuis qu'ils écoutent quels modèles tv
parce qu'on l'avait on l'avait vu il est
très très souvent la voix l'a regardé
envoie sa courbe ici
hum voilà sakho bandes bleues blitz
c'est quoi ça d'ailleurs bien des trucs
là c'est quoi
let
u19
une bizarre en haut mais non alors donc
du coup sa courbe est comme ça et l'or
depuis qui donc depuis à peu près mars
avril mais voilà depuis à quoi j'ai
commencé à un stream et disons des beats
en ligne depuis pas très noble depuis
décembre je crois les premiers donc
décembre janvier
donc depuis qui suis là parce qu'il suit
depuis le début mais il a fortement
progressé alors je sais pas si c'est lié
bien sûr mais on peut supposer que ben
voilà ça l'a aidé à progresser à hervé
66 parce que j'ai l'occasion aussi de
jouer avec lui plusieurs fois
donc bravo à lui en tout cas voilà ça
fait plaisir de voir des joueurs qui
progressent la voilà qui partait là aux
alentours de 1500 et qui a fait un bond
de plus de plus de 100 à 150 points elo
c'est tout à fait que tout à fait
important à 150 points
il va falloir confirmer que ce soit pas
ceux de paille pour hervé 66
donc ça lui à anthony mail salua à zain
mohamed salut à joël salua karens
cantave salut adibou 78
salut agi primo si j prime din din ch
robben strasser qui est un habitué aussi
robben strasser
robben strasser lucas le maho alban fr
le cas le maho qui nous dit que le
meilleur gagne dans le chatt holly chess
alors que dans le tchat
youtube on attend le début reste encore
onze minutes alors à noter que
si vous êtes dans le chatt youtube ou le
chat switch il faut que je me mette sur
twitch aussi parce que des fois il y en
a quelques-uns qui s'ils perdent ce que
je diffuse en parallèle sur les deux
pour l'instant parce que j'ai pas su me
décider en fait sur comment faire
je fais ça pour l'instant de manière un
peu épisodique mais je prends plaisir à
échanger avec vous en direct en tout cas
c'est vrai que c'est sympa
voilà ça y est j'y suis ou chaos voilà
je coupe le reflux pour pas manger de la
bande passante
voilà
alors salut afrique sio fraction y tv
des frictions youtube sans doute qui
nous a rejoints dans le chatt youtube
salut à toi friction ou est ce que free
sio va jouer le tournoi c'est pas sûr
et oui parce qu'on a des spectateurs qui
joue pas et puis on a des joueurs qui
écoute pas donc on en a tous on a des
joueurs qui n'écoutent pas forcément le
stream
il y en a qui a des joueurs qui écoute
le stream en même temps et puis on a des
aussi des spectateurs qui regardent les
partis qui ne jouent pas qu'ils allaient
3 les trois schémas
alors voilà vous avez lu ici un paul
donc un poil ça veut dire un sondage
voilà straw poll ici que vous pouvez
constater ici sur 48 votes je me
demandais quel était vraiment la cadence
préféré quand même
et en tout cas de ce que j'ai pu j'ai
lancé le pôle aujourd'hui j'ai bon c'est
pas énorme 48 votes mais c'est quand
même significatif
je trouve et c'est clairement la cadence
3 + 2 qui l'emportent comme quoi mon
intuition semble être confirmée
bon après il peut y avoir un biais de
confirmation puisque effectivement bon
comme ceux qui participent au débat télé
spirit bits sont des joueurs qui aiment
le 3 + 2 puisqu'on est en 3 plus de bon
maintenant j'ai posté ça aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux donc on a quand même une
vue bon en deuxième arrive la cadence 5
+ 3 donc apparemment quand même un
plébiscite un assez clair sur les
cadences à un crémant que ce soit 3 + 2
ou 5 3 alors que les cadences en un
crémant ne plaisent pas
bizarrement il ya un peu plus de 3 0 que
de 5 0 au camp mais ça m'étonne pas je
crois que quand on est amateur
on préfère les 400 karine clément c'est
sûr que c'est quand même plus sympa a
rajouté deux secondes à chaque coup
trois secondes à chaque coup ça permet
quand même d'être sûrs de priori ne pas
trop tomber autant même si vous avez vu
que c'est quand même mon défaut
principal de tomber autant vous avez vu
que je tourne souvent même avec une
crème en sommes perplexes comme ça parce
que je me perds dans les positions que
j'oublie sou par sou vent de regarder la
pendule
mais je perds moins mais sûre quand il
ya des incréments je suppose que vous
aussi c'est pareil vous préférez alors à
noter que ce pôle vous aller le
retrouver sur le site diagonale tv donc
là aussi vous pouvez consulter ce site
où le problème est dans vos favoris
diagonale tv.com et vous allez sur la
page blitz en ligne
voilà et sur cette page dans sur
diagonale tv vous avez rappel des trois
chaînes vidéo en diagonale tv actuelle
les trois chaînes de streaming en tout
cas ils you tube diagonal tv le tweet
diagonale télé et puis bien sûr la
chaîne diagonale tv imineo échec
où on diffuse aussi voilà donc vous
pouvez retrouver les liens ici ainsi que
le sondage d'ailleurs que j'ai réussi à
l'intégrer dans le site
voilà
donc vous pouvez retrouver ça aussi via
le site diagonale tv si vous savez pas
où c'est vous allez simplement vous là
vous retrouvez aussi les chaînes dans le
menu là maintenant là j'ai rajouté
voyager travailler un peu
je travaille un peu alors j'ai des beaux
jours il ya des questions il ya des
questions alors donc je reviens sur le
tournoi pour pas perdre le début quand
même ce qu'il reste 7 minutes encore
sept minutes 40 beaucoup de questions
allez je me motive pour participer nous
dit échec et amateurs bassem part bravo
échec et amateurs qui ceux qui se
lancent à l'est pour ceux des gones al
tv spirit blitz arena
3 + 2 c'est bien trop rapide pour moi
oui mais bon on peut s'y habituer on
peut s'y habituer el-wafi boîte za salut
salut à toi loisy bouenza je joue aux
frictions youtube l'idylle qui jouent
super ruga attila bonsoir on fait
comment pour s'inscrire alors comment
vous faites pour s'inscrire vous allez
directement
pour s'inscrire alors pour s'inscrire
vous allez ici sur les pièces voilà vous
allez sur la page sur l'équipe diagonale
tv sur lynch est ce vous inscrivez dans
l'équipe et pas besoin d'attendre c'est
automatique
voilà et dans la page de l'équipe vous
avez le tournoi après vous n'avez plus
qu'à cliquer sur le sur le lien du
tournoi et vous vous inscrivez donc il
ya deux inscriptions affaires qui sont
automatiques la première sur l'équipe et
la deuxième dans le tournoi et hop ça y
est vous êtes inscrit si vous n'avez pas
de si vous n'avez pas encore de compte
leach s vous avez encore six minutes
pour en créer un
allez-y c'est gratuit leach s est libre
et gratuit le code de source est libre
et voilà ça n'appartient pas une
entreprise américaine est libre ces
livres est gratuit
c'est fait par un français ça existe
depuis dix ans le code source est libre
il est disponible sur github
voilà c'est un code source voilà libre
comment ça fonctionne du coup mais au
début tivo duplessis que l'ingénieur l'a
fait sur son temps libre et puis petit à
petit il ya plein de gens qui ont fait
des dons pour que ce soit de mieux en
mieux
il a pu du coup si m à plein temps et ça
fonctionne uniquement sur des dons vous
a le droit de faire des dons
alors d'ailleurs diagonale tv pour
l'instant je fais des dons je vais
continuer à en faire envoyer parce que
j'ai la petite la petite elle verte ici
sur le sur le mont petits à côtés de
diagonale tv l'a marqué à gauche ici
voilà où quand je joue il ya la petite
elle est verte qui veut dire que je suis
un mécène des gones mécène de leech et
voilà que je supporte leach s en faisant
des dons réguliers
vous allez droit de faire un don sur
leach s
et vous aurez la petite elle verte aussi
alors
tout inscrire l'équipe diagonale tv
voilà alors l'unicité d'un 06 merci pour
ces vidéos toujours bien commenté merci
à le nissart et bonsoir de chiots que
sofiane ensuite il ya gab
08 04 stéphane ça fait date comment tu
vas ça va super bien merci à toi gab 08
merci à toi
alors oui alors son ami nos échecs des
fois on retrouve des effectivement des
spectateurs qui qui suivent pas
l'actualité des bonal tv alors ils nous
ont perdu de vue mais il faut pas il
faut pas voilà
on a fait des directs sur minos
quand on a fait le festival de perpignan
on a fait une journée de festival de
perpignan
pas cette année mais l'année d'avant je
crois et puis on avait fait aussi le
championnat de france rapide féminin
diffusée sur le mineur échec aussi
et puis là quelques stream de temps en
temps aussi sur lui nos échecs
il ya plusieurs chaînes puisque à la
chaîne twitch aussi moins important
voilà le mieux si vous abonner aux
chaînes ça vous
pas plus de vous serez mis au courant
automatiquement quand tu as comme tient
direct voilà si ça aussi ça vous plaît
bien sûr sinon le sait-on d'e.on et 49
c'est bien déjà c'est très bien il ya
des chances qu'on approche le record de
79 aujourd'hui qu'on ait 49 on peut très
bien
avec les joueurs qui vont arriver à 21h
puisque à 20h30 c'est pas une heure
leach est chassé toutes les heures
pleines
puisqu'il ya des tournois en cours
qui donc il ya des joueurs qui arrêtent
leur tournoi par exemple à 21h à 20h50
il s'arrête et hop ils rejoignent un
autre tournant
salut à tyrone speed salut tyrone speed
il reste trois minutes avant le début de
ce spirit dit serena qui va durer deux
heures quand même pas mal c'est pas trop
loin non plus mais bon le soir j'ai pas
envie de faire trop long
je ferai d'autres sondages
donc vous pouvez répondre au sondage ici
je vais vous le donner à l'adresse du
sondage dans le chatt youtube là
voilà les deux sondages n'hésitez pas à
donner votre avis voilà plus il y aura
de votants plus on sera un conte et
travaux les intérêts je serai peut-être
d'autres sondages après pour les
le jour et l'horaire qui peut vous
convenir le mieux aussi pour faire des
tours - ce serait de faire ça
donc c'est du trois plus de n'y a pas de
berserk je fais pas le truc berserk là
on m6 amusant je dis pas que c'est pas
intéressant c'est intéressant mais bon
je crois que d'ailleurs il ya une
amélioration sur les chaises puisqu'il
ya il me semble que l' appariement les
appariements son été amélioré je crois
au parc on attendre trop longtemps
notamment quand il ya peu de joueurs
dont la saveur avec 50 c'est bon mais
quand il ya des fois y'a que 10 ou 15
joueurs en bêta on peut attendre
beaucoup avant de jouer une partie
je crois que les pièces à améliorer ça
il me semble
alors désolé je n'arrive pas à trouver
le lien du tournoi alors le lien du
tournoi c'est là
voilà
c'est le lien du tournoi mais sinon à la
page de diagonale tv vous le trouvez
voilà alors dans la page du tournoi à
gauche et marquées conditions
d'admission vous de faire partie de
l'équipe diagonale tv vous pouvez
cliquer sur diagonale tv et si vous
cliquez sur des donald tv vous faites
inscriptions annie bonal tv et voilà
c'est réglé
là
c'est bon nous dire où gatti la super en
et 54 c'est bien il ya des chances qu'on
batte le record d'inscriptions
aujourd'hui puisqu'on peut s'inscrire à
n'importe quel moment dans le tournoi
donc il y en a qui arrivent avec 30
minutes de retard
même des fois il y en a qui arrivent au
dernier moment qu'ils foutent ils jouent
les la dernière les dernières trente
minutes ça existe aussi
allez ça va être chaud on va essayer de
faire de belles parties en tout cas
allez
ce qu'il calme
ce
allez c'est parti apparemment il a déjà
qu'on est marc ela
ce qu'il calme monticello non c'est loïc
fourni contre monticello
allez c'est parti c'est parti c'est
parti c'est parti
et moi qu'est ce qui se passe et
j'attends alors
c'est toi
allez c'est parti c'est parti avec
cavaliers 3 qui a été jouée par napoléon
le pro alors napoléon l'éperon va on va
se méfier de lui parce qu'on sait pas ce
qu'il vaut on va jouer avec g6 mais
aussi
faire l'europe
on va jouer
b 6
il ya six c5
allez-vous est calé à 6 1 1 à 3
ces 5
pensé comme un joueur qui joue qui joue
pas trop mal là donc il va falloir faire
attention
jouer avec tours s'est vite
c'est peut-être leur ici pour cavalier e
4 donc mon pièces sont sortis prix
initié
peut-être avec eve scène pour consolider
puis en 4 n'est pas mal ce pion libyen
avançaient à ça ça perd une pièce
sapeurs le
alors je peux prendre à trois mais je
vais plutôt revenir la maison je préfère
regarder mon fou sur cette diagonale
l'or
on va jouer avec cavaliers huit tombes à
revenir à la maison
jouer quel et 17
l'idée c'est de venir à 1,5 et après on
a de belles cases ici
on va sans doute maintenant jouer avec
[Musique]
mais donne des six probablement les
dames des six
autour des 8 l'idée c'est de jouer aussi
ce bien sûr tôt ou tard donc là on prend
prise prise la dame peut pas venir nous
embêter à connaître grâce aux pions qui
contrôle tout 1
granby on peut prendre de la tour on
laisse le cavalier reprendre peut-être
certes c'est un peu embêtant moi je vois
mon 17
on a gagné quand même une pièce
j'ai pris de la tour pour pas que je
n'avais pas envie que cette dame
viennent ici bon j'aurais pu quand même
peut-être un mais
on me semblait un peu
me semblait peu rigoureux
on veut ouvrir la ligne contre ce roi
ici on se moque de repères de la pièce
ici qu'on va ouvrir toutes les lignes et
en gardant le cavalier agents pêche la
dame de devenir m'embêter rapidement bon
on va voir ce que ça donne
on prend
ok maintenant on doit pouvoir prendre de
la dame tout simplement ça doit éliminer
tout facilement voilà le cavalier cloud
et de toute façon c'est pas moyen de le
défendre je crois
parce que même s'il fait tour ici il ya
tour prat et suroît ici il suffit de
faire un échec et ça y est on récupère
ça va attaquer les deux tours ici
ouais bien vu mais ya échec subi 2
échec
enfin on va voir simplement
prendre la pièce
avec une partie gagnante merci à napoli
en outre le procafé une erreur
essentiellement il a juste oublié des
pièces au passage surtout au début
voilà ici grosse erreur ici ça a été
tout simplement de pousser voilà oublier
qu en poussant un pion on libère la colo
la diagonale ici voilà merci à la polir
le cros pour cette première partie
combien de ronde alors tyrone speed me
demande combien de ronde alors ça c'est
la particularité leach s y a pas de
route définie dès que vous avez terminé
une partie vous enchaînez
voilà leach sp1 a pareillement en temps
réel
la prise
j'ai c'est autre chose il faudrait que
j'essaie aussi cavalière si cela
ça au jour c'est ça ma vie ça a l'air
pas mal ça m'a bien plu
g 3g trop g3
je vais trop le foot je veux c'est sûr
j'ai trois faut jouer 5
c'est certain
5 parce que ça a maintenant des quatre
deviennent délicat et c'est jouer bien
sûr mais c'est délicat alors à 6 pour
éviter d
des cavaliers b5 quand je joue qu'avait
laissé six parce que si vous qu'à les
baisser un peu embêté donc là maintenant
qu'elle et ses six défend des formes 5
vite là maintenant on empêche le ici le
clouage du pion aux cinq donc je mets le
fou devant le roi
et maintenant de pouvoir au quai
tranquilla joue peut-être h6 avant
voilà je joue à 6 6 avant je jouais si
ça va j'ai pas envie qu'ils viennent
m'éliminer ce cavalier ce câble et
contrôler les caser ici surtout la case
ou karachi pas envie de me prendre un
cavalier aux 4,4 cris madame voilà
autre
les d4
tat la dame
rend les choses un peu délicate ici
pour les blancs
oui
alors ici on peut prendre ici
[Musique]
échec puis prendre h3
c'est possible dans ce cas là il ya
tourbe et 8
et où va le fou
on n'a pas beaucoup de burqa
et
alors plus en plus vite l'intérêt de
bibitte six attaques b2 ce qui fait que
ce fou alors a du mal à sortir le
phocéen
damas 3 ok dame est roi c'est
intéressant
interesting mauvais
2 les styles move
mon
tranquille
6 c'est bizarre
plus blanc crack complet la donne une
pièce gratuite
c'est pas un oubli c'est un craquage
crac houllier côté blanc la wii mais
tous 77 qui a perdu un peu les pédales
on sortir de l'ouverture semble-t-il
hockey ou bien on se retrouve en tête
alors on va essayer de goûter ce moment
parce que c'est pas sûr qu'on finisse en
tête il ya quand même beaucoup de très
bons joueurs
est ce que vous savez jouer à la veuve
d'une demande de tyrone speed oui je
peux jouer à la veille mais ça
m'intéresse pas je trouve c'est
dangereux pour la santé mentale j'y
crois pas trop
mais arrivé de le faire mais bon ça très
intéressant
aller de 4 c'est spectaculaire mais
alors c'est qu'un oui alors là on va
jouer avec ses 4 allez on va jouer comme
ça on a vu qu'on avait obtenu de bons
résultats avec ça parce que ça sort
revendre des schémas
c'est pas c'est pas forcément hyper
hyper forains comme début mais ça
l'intérêt de sortir l'adversaire de ses
habitudes
voilà alors
juhasz 3 ou est-ce qu'on fait le petit
robe d'abord
je joue h3g pas envie qu'il veut plein
de fougue et 4 kim élimine un cavalier
en fait je veux garder mes cavaliers
petit rock
il veut jouer 5
veut jouer 5 le bon grain semble-t-il
ma foi
je vous des trois temps
le
quel nécessaire
jouer de fou 3
pour b 1
alors 5 est possible puisque ça il ya le
cavalier qui sera attaquée
17 17
les uns des six
on fait ça on va voir en ce qui se passe
je pousse puisque là il ya le cav a
laissé six qui a attaqué et derrière il
ya aussi la torah vite
voyez donc en poussant ben on va voir
voilà du coup on va prendre ici ou là
l'idée simple c'est que c'est de jouer
cavalier 4 c'était seul je voulais faire
voilà maintenant il ya ça qui attaquer
ici pouces il ya ses seins qui tombent
semble-t-il
c'est pas facile de défendre
c'est pas
fendre
donc c'est un peu risqué à ce qui a été
fait ces enjeux semble-t-il
bon on va voir
oui ça c'est possible dans le set
est-ce que je joue fou
gsm peut-être les 5 ha les fous j'ai
cinq attaques la dame m6 ou f4
alors là l'intérêt de forcer les noirs
juifs 6 convient de faire c'est que ça
bloque un peu le fou g7
mais non sur ford 4 on attaque des 6 2
fois
alors ça c'est possible
jouer des 4
pensez 4d prendre 5
il cavale et prend derrière on ne me
prend je sais pas
simplement tout re 1
aux jo turun ont mis le tour en face de
la dame ça fait toujours
j'ai toujours de la pression jamais
facile de savoir quoi faire quand on a
une tour en face
jouer des quatre il me semble aller au
bout des quatre maintenant
des complications ici
c'est très compliqué la position là
les prisons c5
ans clément rouby
chose ici
et oui mais là ils ont billet là ils ont
oublié le câble et c7 simplement
ça pardonne pas
et la tourbe et 8 est attaqué
alors on fait [ __ ] des six
je pense ou alors on fait fouet kadjé 5
on fait tous des six b6 pour pas perdre
de temps
[Musique]
et on va prendre de la dame pour essayer
d'éliminer des pièces maintenant qu'on a
une pièce de plus quand on a une pièce
de plus faut jouer davantage
matériel
et on peut le faire en échangeant des
pièces
tout simplement
et maintenant donc on peut jouer sans
doute ici à ont tous joué fou échec
et abandon alors là parce que là le roi
est obligé d'aller là et après on fait
échec ici
et je pas sûr qu'on ramasse ceux du
matériel d'ailleurs suis pas sur mais
bon le faire abandonner
ok
on a gagné cette partie bon démarre très
fort on démarre très fort avec trois
victoires pour l'instant c'est de la
chance un peu je dirais on est chanceux
on est chanceux dans ce diagonale tv
spirit beats arena la halle et leucate a
été joué donc allé j'ai dit que je
chante j'ai un peu ou pas
ouais je continue avec des 5% des bons
résultats je tente aurait autre chose
quand l'occasion se présente terrain
comme je le sentirai un peu plus car
lille 6
pas mal cette ouverture en fait soit en
compte donc c'est la scandinave
alors là on avait dit aux 5 c'est ce
qu'on a fait tout à leur fougue et de
était joué
voici ce avec l'idée de jouer les c6
voilà
moi c'est ça même parti tout à l'heure à
b3 a été jouée mais trois je suis pas
sûr
est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer fou ou g4
on en prend kamel et d4
4 on peut aussi faire foi je sais on
n'est pas obligé de
voilà on va faire le grand roque direct
[Musique]
et on va reculer on va le laisser
s'affaiblir un peu parce que quand on
pousse les pions s'affaiblit
wade 3d 3d 3 ça leur salaire salaire
très bas jouent au chat mans
pas jouer ou 4 je peux jouer cavalier
des cats n'ont qu'à les d4
et pas mieux que ça quel et décale ça me
parlait ça n'a pas l'air très très bons
vins plus tôt
[Musique]
fou
pour nous
traiter fait ok quand c'est intéressant
de jouer x 3
c'est bien vu
va jouer tour la jeu
ce
et ça continue
oui ça c'est pas mal je vous donne
décède tout simplement
pour avec une opposition intéressante
et non un pion au centre ici le pion aux
5 alors que les blancs n'ont ils ont le
pion mais en d3 qui moins intéressant je
pense
ok bon il faut prendre simple
vous
fois peut-être
oui on va prendre
prendre deux fois
aller et on l'a fait
pion à non il n'ya pas fou prend mais ce
sera fou prend ici
alors
page web 6 du coût
en me 6
clan peut jouer fou ici sans doute
dans un premier temps on attaque 4
le cavaly ok donc on va jouer on va
laisser ça comme ça
tout est cavalier des quatre maintenant
à les cavaliers des quatre là on n'est
pas trop mal je pense aux cavaliers pas
mal quand même
alors prise prise
une minute mais il y aurait on a plus de
secondes donc ça va scandinaves ou six
jensen scandinave
la chance sourit aux audacieux
moi qui avais pas de bersée venant ya
pas de verser qu'un je crois pas
oui parce que je suis en quasi berserk
c'est ça ok donc on va jouer avec g5
pour fixer les pions blanc sur blanc que
justement on les fixe
pour 17
tout autour des 6 tc 6 peut-être pas
comme ça
ok donc là on va jouer avec
le détour je pense que mon cavalier pas
trop mal ici
moi
et on va jouer
kallio 6 on est une belle case ici
alors
sont peut-être joué ces cinq ici
on va jouer ces 5
[Musique]
alors
ce qu'il faut prendre ici ou jouer à 5
tout de suite on joue à 5 pour fixer les
pions
toujours l'idée de fixer les pions qu'a
prises le cavalier va pouvoir reprendre
tout simplement
on peut aussi jouer ces quatre ici
prendre les pions quand je veux aller je
joue c'est 4 je crois qu'il a il est un
peu coincé ici même si j'ai mis le pion
sur blanc en ce qu'il a pas moyen de
venir embêter ce pion il est coincé de
l'autre côté
donc je sais pas si ça gagne mais je
pense que ça perd pas
qui est déjà un bon point
ce
je peux m'amuser longtemps ici sans
risque
allez on va avancer comme ça
e
revenir
passé par là
hop
qu'est ce qu'il va faire
ou ici
va pas être facile de passer là
essayez quand même
voilà on attaque le pion
on joue ici
alors puis on pousse
on prend
alors eux
si on va peut-être jouer là
à l'école et t3 est possible ici
[Musique]
maintenant
ça devrait gagner l'opinion je pense
ouais le pion c3
un peu long mais
olemps et d'insulter les positions c'est
que vous avez le fou qui est mauvais et
vous êtes obligés d'attendre alors je
peux me tromper bien sûr mais
donc c'est les noirs qui peuvent essayer
de gagner c'est beaucoup plus dur à
essayer de gagner pour les blancs
alors maintenant j'ai un pion de plus
du terrain est passée par là
échec
c'est ici
voilà ça y est c'est fini
échec et voilà le seimat au prochain
coup soit en b3 son nouveau look est
super en b3
c'est terminé moi une partie un peu
technique et on à loïc fournier l'inca
car enchaîner les victoires là il a fait
un deuil à boire des bières celle du
coin parce qu'effectivement il a marqué
trois points tout à l'heure je crois
qu'il avait pas de verser effectivement
je n'ai peut-être pas à éliminer le ver
sec c'est possible
bah tant pis si on ajoute du sel à au
tournoi c'est pas plus mal
a lieu 4 c 5 allée pareil je vais jouer
cette façon de jouer là
avec g3
il vaut mieux avoir imposé un cavalier
dans les positions bloquer ou semi
bouquet way exactement tout à fait bien
vu
ah les cavaliers ou deux
on fait le petit rock
ou détroit se consolide nos pions du v6
hommage au tour b 1
pourra pas répéter indéfiniment il
faudra bien que m'ont donné ils changent
parce que sinon ils voir se retrouver
avec des problèmes de visas vis
pas répéter indéfiniment aux échecs en
symétrie ou d'un moment ça marche pas
alors f5 a été fait ok 500 est récent
c'est une crise il faut jouer f4e est-ce
qu'on peut laisser jouer f4 ou f4 prise
prison gagne un pion ici il prend lui on
peut reprendre d'une pièce si on veut ou
d'hommes qui ont donc on continue notre
notre idée on le laisse
on le laisse jouer ça ok ça c'est
possible
donc ça ça permet de
envisager de jouer qu'elle ait des 5
vous dites cavaliers des 5-6 s'y prend
il
après la reprise le cavalier bouger donc
je pourrais jouer les quatre restants je
peux pas jouer b4 j'aurais pu attendre
un peu chaud tu joues et peut-être sous
des deux aussi mais bon
le cas des cinq un peu
trop rapide aujourd'hui je fus d2t
peut-être plus sages des deux d'abord
mais bon
yossi dorfman a récemment conseillé
cette ligne avec ses 4 pour les blancs
il disait que c'est intéressant abba
super merci besoin de rien envie de toi
qu'ils me disent 'ah 6 a été jouée est
ce que c'est moi qui ai perdu du temps
ou pas non je crois pas alors b4 prise
prise cavale et prendre des 5 à la fin
il prend ici donc ça va pas
donc
jouets ou des deux allez je joue ou des
deux
et puisque le fou ici contrôle ici donc
pour jouer b4 c'est plus facile
tech avec le foulage peut aussi jouer
des fois des dames c'est un et ça crée
un petit problème sur la justice pas
forcément très grave mais
donc les noirs en tiennent compte moment
donné quand même peut-être voilà donc
ici qui bouge
très bien peut-être on peut jouer f4 non
mais aussi
c'est les blancs essayer de ses devoirs
ce que les blancs vont faire ici
faut 6 quelques saucisses
alors b4 est possible maintenant parce
que j'ai vraiment envie de faire ça
c'est pas sûr
c'est un peu
il faut y aller je pense aller même si
ça ouvre la colonne à 1 pour les pour
les pour les noirs bon alors il a repris
du pillon
il a repris du pillon donc je gardais
mon fou du coup les reprendre du
cavalier
garde du le fou je pensais qu'il allait
prendre en d5 d'abord mais ça attaque et
du coup sont effectivement ça attaquer
aurait pu prendre du fou en fait en d5
je reprenais du pian et reprenez du
cavalier il fallait je donne mon fou
mais bon pourquoi pas
attention s'il prend je reprends du
cavalier
s'il prend pas maintenant il a un
problème sur le pion bessette
ça le fait d'avoir repris en b 4 en
éloignant des pions du centre il a
éloigné des pions du centre puisqu'il en
a plus que deux au centre à l'étroit
avec le pion f5 et moi j'en ai quatre
voilà donc je vais un peu plus un peu
plus massivement présents au centre dans
le grand centre je dirais
c'est un genre des taux de marc au xi e
s on peut dire ça oui ça ressemble bien
sûr ça ressemble on est d'accord
bien sûr ça ressemble à des tournois
roxy clairement
alors
il fait il fait tout retour à 3 aura 3
qui est un peu curieux je trouve
ça me permet de vous deux tours b 3 on
dirait
allez ça me permet de vous tour b 3
oui
key
je vous nomme ces deux
attention si on veut jouer aux dames
c'est 2
on joue dams et 2
voilà l'idée maintenant c'est
peut-être de doubler sur la colonne b
pour faire attention puisque comme j'ai
joué quatre f4 là il ya des tensions ici
ça peut s'ouvrir il peut y avoir des
échecs ici il faut que je fasse gaffe
pas qu'il puisse placer un cavalier là
mais bon pour l'instant savard il peut
pas sont trop loin ses cavaliers
ça pourrait arriver un jour ou l'autre
ok donc là on va jouer deux tours b 1
[Musique]
ce retour prend à trois aussi
dray il a des problèmes on t'a on l'a
maintenant puisqu'il reste que six
secondes donc il prend trop de temps
beaucoup trop de temps
et donc la tour prends
ok
ces trois à l'air pas mal
et cavaliers
ça doit perdre mais j'ai l'impression
que ça perd
ah non ça perd pas ce que je pensais que
après tout rien ils n'avaient pas de
casse pour la dame messi
on va prendre le 5
oui
et on peut jouer tomber 700
j'ai vérifié qui a pas d'échec pénible
ok donc ça c'est possible
jouer
h3 ici on essaie de cacher le roi
si ça a été joué
et on a gagné autant
il a trop de temps là il est tombé sur
le même piège que moi
avoir trop réfléchi en beach ça pardonne
pas c'est vrai que c'est pas facile
alors vous avez tous les deux pères de
fouet position pas trop ouverte ouais
c'est vrai passé des positions
compliquées
c'est pas évident
et donc on peut faire des berserk la
part des joueurs qui versait avec un bon
ceci dit c'est très dangereux de bercy
qui je pense dans dans des cadences de
type 3 + 2 parce que vous avez je crois
que mon père c'est que vous vous
retrouvez avec une minute trente sans
ajout de temps
donc du coup
vous êtes vraiment ko quoi autant alors
que l'adversaire à plus de deux secondes
vous avez vraiment intérêt de jouer très
très très bien ne pouvait perdre y
compris face à des adversaires
clairement monde fort que vous
juste parce qu'il joue il joue
correctement sans faire trop d'erreurs
et il a du temps
donc c'est du temps qui se rajoutent
surtout donc vous n'êtes pas le faire
tomber
alors d 4d 4 on va jouer cavalier pts 6
allez on va jouer avec eux scène qu'on a
eu des bons résultats dernièrement avec
ça
quels liens que les c6
en fait l'échec
dams est honoré pouvoir récupérer le
simple maintenant donc là ya pas trop
trop le choix il faut prendre en d2
et enfin
en 5
esprit 6
ces trois joué très vite un plat il me
fait un peu peur donc des six donc il
vous donne ses trois très rapidement
huawei
théorique ça et je dois être dans la
panade je suppose
bon bon bon bon c'est pas grave
moi sortir nos pièces
clement
loin de jouer
3 était joué
ok ici
on va rockets
bel hommage autour de 8 du coût pour
huit là tout va bien parce qu'en cas de
prise je peux reprendre la dame et j'ai
pas je pense que j'ai pas casser mes
pions
c'est l'heure d'aller
c'est pas hyper
c'est pas on n'est pas forcément mieux
mais parce qu'on n'est pas moins bien la
part de fou ce qui fait qu effectivement
ça peut ça peut ça peut être pénible
qui donc la rescousse et 5 ou 6 et 6,5
c'est si ça leur bien joué ces six 6 ie6
et on n'est pas si mal
ces partis d'opposition que je cherchais
arthur ans du bon alors tour d2 a été
jouée tour d2 était joué donc bon ok
pour des deux a été jouée je peux pas
jouer tour des huit puisque retour prend
et après je perdrais lecavalier cali 1,5
donc là j'ai un problème avec mon
quatrième scène qui faut que j'arrive à
le placer ailleurs alors je vais penser
je vais le placer ici je pense
je le place ici là l'idée maintenant
c'est de passer soit par b6 soit par six
et de contrôler les quatre centrales
notamment la casse des 5
voilà donc la b6 ou bien m6 m6 je peux
me faire clouer donc je vais faire
plutôt b6 voilà paraît logique
ça va ça va
ok ou f3 est possible bien sûr non mais
là on peut jouer x 4
et je crois qu'on n'est pas si mal
[Musique]
hong kong
si mal puisque on va pouvoir jouer
cavalier des 5
et que une position intéressante
peut-être prendre un 4
là maintenant mon cavalier il attend que
ça d'aller en d5
chess ok alors
ce que les dessins tout de suite
qu'est ce qu'on peut ajouter la carte
la dame quand même c'est pas mal
que les c5 derrière
où joue aussi soit katia
4 54
bonjour et 15,6 france
6 tout simplement
ok
trop d'hommes ckd d'emprunt qu'elle les
prend
ces quatre à l'aube la dame surnomment
ses 4
on fait comme ses quatre
changer cette dame a priori je pense que
e
oui
détroit ici
m6
trente secondes contre 46
dans bay 4 4 dans lequel de mes 4
d4
trois sets
que
dom
dans le iv
on joue ici
brest 12 secondes ok d'am dam des six on
peut jouer cavalier c4
ouais ouais donc ici attention prise
prise échec échec
on peut jouer ça aille et non ça c'est
pas bon ça c'est pas bon art
me suis trompé
ah mince
ouais je me suis trompé accomplis vers
la fin à dommage
la cgt un peu sous pression ici ça
allait
là je suis pas inquiet d'un échec je
peux revenir là sur un échec que
toujours jouer ça
j'ai de prendre les trois prises dans
prend messiah preuve de tout simplement
je cherchais une attaque ici et je me
suis trompé
des jouets à fitch s
mais première défaite de la soirée
il n'avait joué
alors quels conseils à donner pour se
constituer un répertoire lorsqu on est
débutant aux mêmes joueurs
intermédiaires
je vous conseille de lire le livre du
grand philidor voilà quand on est
débutant il faut commencer par le début
du jeu d'échecs
au début la théorie et ça c'est philidor
allez on joue au moulin des reformes où
il avait gagné le tournoi samedi dernier
la
vous nous avez gagné le deluna tv spirit
beats arena à la semaine dernière
du samedi le tournoi du samedi
des trois tours bien
[Musique]
cavaliers des 4 on va prendre
quel 2
food et 2
non
or c'est plus ou moins les change de ces
fous là et ça c'est pas mal pour
affaiblir un peu le roi adverse
la note
joubaud le higuain c'est stéphane bien
sûr
alors si vous avez perdu pied avec
diagonale tv on est toujours présent et
vous allez sur diagonale tv.com et puis
vous allez sur la chaîne youtube
diagonale tv
voilà
parce que ça veut dire que vous avez pas
vous avez pas vu qui avait fait notre
chaîne ok prise prise à l'est
alors qu'elle et ses six ont pu vous des
oui et ce 4 août
il
eh bien on va commencer à ouvrir le jeu
parce que on a un roi qui s'est
affaiblie du fait que le foot recasement
a disparu donc on n'ouvre le feu
dans des deux
juncker
dom
moi
oui
tour d un on augmente ici la pression
sur potentiel ici sont des six
en même temps sur protège aussi le câble
et des 4
à noter aussi que ce fou pourrait
peut-être venir en f1 défendre le point
sensible c4
au cas où
j'ai pas de risque de cavaliers ici
parce que j'ai le cas
alliée et la dame qui défendent f3
voilà sa défense ok ça c'est pas mal
ça c'est pas mal du tout petit bijou et
d525 un très bon coup
parce que trop bon j'ai mis dix ans
on peut jouer c'est ça une peut-être
ces quatre tout simplement
ok
que l'on prend
ok ah ça permet de prendre
c'est à mon avis une
maintenant j'ai deux pions passée lille
très très dangereux ça
grosse faute des noirs qu'on lâche et un
pion qu'il fallait surtout pas perdre
c'est pas tellement que le pion aussi
c'est important c'est surtout ces deux
là maintenant soit important
à noter que deux maintenant je domine le
cabrio 5 alors là je vais 5
elle était de bayssan c'est que s'est
défendue par le cavalier par le fou et
que ça évite que les noirs contrôler la
case ici à casa 4
pas de contrôle maintenant
la position blanche est très très bonne
ici
alors
5 a été joué
trt
ah c'est pas mal
attention bien ne pas
nous mater de ce côté là
on peut jouer quatre noms j'ai
l'impression que ça perd une pièce ce
que la lecavalier n'a pas de case de
repli
il est pris par ses propres pièces et de
bain il est dominé par le fou regarde et
comme tout ça est coincé pour le
cavalier voilà ils obligés de faire ça
ah oui ça perd pas de pièce parce qu'il
ya ça d'accord ok
ok ok ok bon
bon bon bon d'accord
d'accord je vais faire une bêtise donc
on va faire ça on va faire plus tôt dom
tom c'est 4
b 2
ces deux
c'est pourquoi
je peux prendre tout reprend
marche pas
je sais pas quoi faire ici ce qui est
pas normal
allez dans la 3
et ce prise
38 secondes j'ai pris trop de temps
mais j'arrive vraiment pas avoir quoi
faire st
ça c'est bizarre prendre ici
en attaque la tour est en même temps
maintenant voilà mais là il ya el cheikh
puis adam prend
tout reprend et tout va bien
we want is ok
white is totally ok là
mais on va simplement il changer les
dames
là c'est terminé
la partie est clairement de gagner en
toile a donc abandonné de mou 68000
brand mais c'est pas mal parce que et il
nous menait au score l'animal 3 2 donc
il mené 3 1 avant cette partie est donc
là on revient un peu au score
il ya 3 3 3 en fait après cette partie
apparemment non non je suis parti à 3 2
des 3
ok allez oust faut faire attention à
moumour 68000 haï laiteries qui y pose
plein piège
robben strasser qui en a il est en super
forme il a 25 points donc il a pris son
temps par contre un il a joué moins de
parti mais il s'est appliqué et la
raison et du coup les biens partis là
un parti habite chez king alors bits sur
king dont ceux qu'on mène au score donc
il faut être prudent parce que
des 5 alors dessin nous on va jouer que
les c3 on évite là aussi
les rangs trop pointu
or
ou jouer avec un f4 direct
pour que c'est intéressant de jouer avec
80 direct
cliffs 3
ok
parce que jouer ses trois ici ou non
bonjour et détroit du coup
e
[Musique]
ce qui se passe ici
si les noirs se sont pas un peu
peut tromper un peu viande est là ici
peut-être fou g5 intermédiaire
attac la dame
il faut prendre ici maintenant
que
sinon enfin
ou pas pour une fois je crois peut-être
3 à l'erreur pas mal j'aime bien fois je
crois sinon on fouette un peu un peu tué
par les pions là
page 5 a été jouée je voyais dam des
deux
l'autre
possible
g4 est possible animal alors mais qu'est
ce qui se passe si on prend ce qui se
passe on va prendre
et qu'elle allait prendre 5 devoir de
gagner un pion
prise
c'est jamais tout et damages 6
si c'était un coup était un coup un peu
violent pas sûr que les noirs et pas
joué un peu trop vite la prison j'ai
trois cas les c3 anti scandinave
oui bah disons en tout cas ça évite les
grandes variantes ouais je suis pas du
tout la validité du coup honnêtement je
suis très expérimentale comme joueur en
fait j'aime bien tenter des trucs alors
ça j'ai prévu il ya des matches cinq
échecs
dans prend avec échec
et abandon voilà ce qu'on a gagné une
pièce on va il peut même pas jouer roy
un des six passes qui auraient échec si
je crois au cices
je peux choisir de faire encore un échec
là enfin bref
beaucoup de possibilités pour les blancs
en tout cas avec une grosse pièce de
plus au quai
donc bon je crois que là on a réussi à
l'avoir je demande la réouverture voilà
parce qu'on est sorti des schémas parce
que quand les joueurs jouent sur leur
schéma qui connaissent bien vous pouvez
pas les surprendre si vous jouez une
ouverture un peu bizarre on peut alors
faut faire attention parce que les
ouvertures bizarre qui sont pas bonnes
et je sais que je joue son source au
sens
beaucoup qui doivent pas être très bonne
en fait mais mais bon
pression du jeu on peut arriver à voile
à surprendre
et à marquer des points
elle est bien vous êtes vous avez vu la
paire de foule 1 la paire de fou ça va
bien si la position est ouverte mais la
position n'était pas ouverte et puis
surtout le roi n'avait pas ok il y avait
d'autres éléments plus importants alors
tiens on joue robben strasser tient bien
on va aller moi je vous remet à changer
un peu
on va vous coller des cinq quand je
voyais des six
alors c4 c4 que les v6
oui donc là
alors évidemment je vais pas prendre de
la dame parce que si je prends de
l'adami la c5 qui gagne une pièce donc
là je peux apprendre du pion sait où
depuis qu'ils ont cessé bien
en tout cas ça l'air de l'avoir surpris
un peu la maintenance et de l'idc sortir
par là avec une structure de type
dragons 1
et tous g7
du rock
donc
les c6
boujou 5 alors tes 5 décembre dès samedi
alors des 5 ce qui est intéressant dans
l'allée keynes et le coup cavale et a5
souvent comment protège sa s'est jamais
simple
s'il vous plaît 3 il peut des fois se
prendre dès le 4 mai annonce alors de
tenir
achetez f5 derrière aussi possible
mais bon on va on va la jouer tranquille
on va jouer avec elle cette suis pas sûr
que ce soit le mieux
les cas la scène j'aime bien ce genre de
couple s'est tendu le son se dit on est
impatient pour les 5es perdu et s'est
jamais le cas parce qu'à cause du pion
c4 ou pas on peut pas jouer ce qu'on
veut
je te laisse 5
tac le fou
auj
passé ce responsable
donne nous faut trois hockey
on pressent d'aller le prendre et f5
avec une partie qui est pas trop mal je
pense pour les noirs ici
on l'a typiquement la paire de fouet est
intéressante mais pour l'instant aller
bon vu que les pions sur aube îlot
central peut être pas mal quand même
si j'arrive à ouvrir des lignes ça peut
être bien l'épaule ça n'est pas de
lignes ouvertes mais bon le jeu est pas
bloqué donc on peut on peut espérer
avoir des lignes ouvertes
alors un jour 17
non non c'est non
qu'a-t-on plus
17 j'ai peur de ces scènes prises
d'hommes france un peu pénible comment
se demande ici
par mesdames c'est un truc comme ça mais
comme cette c'est pas mal je faisais mes
sept ans
il perd combien de cancon coup à un fou
très convaincu
tours s'est vite je pense qu'il a raté
des trucs ici intéressant mais
combien
est ce que je fais 4
peut-être c'est bien
4 est pas mal
on peut jouer fouet pts 5
c'est bien fou aux 5
ce que s'ils jouent à saint qui
m'attaquent lecavalier j'ai pas
cavalier à 8 donc comme ça je le remets
en 17 c'est pour ça que je joue faux f5
en même temps que je contrôle aussi une
case centrale voilà
détroit ok mais ça ça me dérange pas
trop trop ce qu'ils pouvaient faire que
les dix-sept des 4 à 5
alors pas mal hein
parce qu'ils veulent que louis que 17 et
pas mal je pense qu'elle est 17 est
intéressant j'ai envie bien sûr de
mettre mon cavalier en c5
waouh c'est simple
il faut prendre aussi
ou prendre les c5
4 marche pas ici le 4
reese
allez on prend
et 11 août a laissé cinq
attaquants b3
l'on peut jouer à 5 sécurisé la casse b4
on va jouer le g5 ici avec l'idée de
jouer à 5 h à g4 prime empêche
est-ce que je reste un peu obligé de
prendre là du coup n'ont pas sûr
e
je joue à six sans doute raté une
combine mais à 30 secondes ouhlala faut
que le salaire et on va être mal
ouais c'est bien joué de sa part il faut
que je récupère du temps surtout pour
des coûts rapidement
si c'est pas des coûts excellent mais il
faut que je faut que je joue des coûts
vite 9 secondes
les prises
dames g6 hockey 2007
cette année
un pas
là
art
comme un bleu
quand même
on va monter
infini
ok ici
je vous la suite ça peut être utile
moi simplement jouer b6
prison france ancien
on pas donc on reprendre ici
klaus prise
les deux
fini
parti restait un tantinet compliqué
celle qui monte
moi je joue ici
partir est un peu complexe revenue
hanter autant
ok on va faire échec
allez-vous c5
logique
pour b 5 ont fait échec
prises dont on va prendre
pouces
eh ouais
portées avec un match final voilà on va
dire qu'on était mal autant essayer de
forcer un peu et on a eu un peu de
réussite mais on a pas on n'a pas craqué
là on n'a pas craqué avec une position
très délicate
j'ai manqué de pousser au 4 sans doute
plus tôt il fallait que je poussais
jsbn ce qui nous a rejoints dans le
tchat
ouais j'ai oublié la pendule mais voyez
que je me suis réveillé à temps car
quand giscard destinée
samlan ali king ouest et na li qin loïc
bourgeois loïc joubaud par donc jouer à
les chiens on va jouer avec quatre jeux
variés un peu
allez on va jouer notre
spécial anti anti française avec des
trois jours que d un petit truc pour
l'instant
2-4 soins ajouté cho de choses chez 3
c'est bien de jouer plusieurs trucs
parce que ça maintient éveillé
oula ça ça oubliez un pion
c'est pas un truc à faire où
jouer avec ses 3 1 et calais
autre
faire ça je joue
quel 2
on va voir ce que font les noirs et
pas les petits rock
ces trois décades je vais jouer ses
trois d'abord pour voir
j'arrive à des quatre prises prise
c java garder ce pion tout en ouvrant le
jeu je pense que c'est très très bon
brice prise peut pas jouer quatre là
donc du coup il va être obligé voilà
depuis un peu de prendre
elle a raté
des trucs qui font trop vite il faut
trop vite
en tout cas les c4
les fous g5
deux parties là
très bonne partie
la c
très risqué ce que font les noirs ici
mettent leur leurs dames en face d'une
tour là
commence à sentir le roussi
je menace aussi de prendre les psys
savait qu'une destruction complète de
rock voilà
[Musique]
prendront peut jouer derrière allez on
va prendre
et maintenant on peut jouer
cavalier prendre d'en prendre cavaliers
f5 et c'est terminé
ouais c'est bon allez cavalli prend
des six
il va aussi reprendre
il ya quatre cinq et le problème de
qualif 5,6 attaque la dame et en même
temps se contrôler la case us est donc
la menace ces dames
j'ai quatre échecs et ses maths alors à
il ya encore dame b 4 ok le corps d'un
bébé 4
qui sauve un peu apparemment ce que je
peux pas venir angers 4 sur dame b 4
la question c'est ce que la dame a des
quinzaines on n'a pas de case suffit de
jouer à trois
la dame a pas de gaz elle a plus qu à
quatre et aprilia b3
voilà serre s'ils avaient joué damas 4
ici joue à trois la dame a pas de casse
ni là ni là ni là ni la tout ça est pris
part soit la dame soit le cavalier sur
le fou donc il ya plus que la casa
quatre ans cajou b3 et l'a obligé de
partir de cette rangée du monde qui part
ya échec et mat
ok
salut avec perche ever
alors deux cas les 6 3 la france et
c'est intéressant aussi avec aleph trois
prestations des grandes variantes
théorie queer oui et non c'est pas si
clair parce que c'est pas si facile ça
reste théorique cavale et ses 3 c'est
pas ça reste assez analysé alors que
quatre à lyon va jouer dessin une face à
max white en 68 max walter 68
on va reculer
ou f5 yes
si on va jouer qu'elle épaississe
des trois à six
est
waouh
ca c
ça c'est pour le moins responsables ça
que 17
oui
au cices
aliot 6 tu es un peu fou
pour cet
cavalli h3
c'est simple peut-être
[Musique]
comme ces six daims b6
comme ces six
c'est peut-être tout c'est un jour c'est
c'est peut-être un jour on pousse
on va rockets seller
pas
3,8
et les cinq attaques
[Musique]
dans ces huit de ces quatre
gagner 4 1
calais b 6 toujours dans l'idée de jouer
ces 4 et puis pour éviter des x 4 en cas
de prise prise n'y a pas deux fois 4 à
cause du cavalier et la tour par ok mes
pièces sont bien placés faut juste que
j'arrive à tuer un peu fou parce que
c'est un peu dangereux quand même avec
son foulard pour l'instant ça va il ya
beaucoup de pièces qui le gêne mais
on est pas que ça ça dégénère
et pour l'instant ça va
waouh
non
il peut faire ça
kippa sur b4
que les biens
à 5
allez aimer 4
il s'est mis juste en face d'eux
de ma batterie tour dames là
prise alors prise prise prise qu'est ce
qu'on fait là prendre du plomb du pian
bien sûr
pour le pion
évidemment comprendre pions
après il ya 5 à 4
avoir des problèmes ici
s'il prend on peut prendre du plomb et
il a un problème ici parce que attention
il a une tour qui est en face d'une dame
ici et le fait quand même ça c'est
risqué
quand même très risqué ce que fait notre
amie
il est en train de se mettre en plein
devant la batterie 1
ok donc ça c'est pas mal parce que parce
que parce que c'est bien c'est bien tout
simplement lampe jouer à 5
c'est pas grave
allez vous à 5 il peut jouer qu'à les
f-5 mais dans ce cas là il faut 6
ou même poussé 5 peut-être
pas des masses de cazin
les cinq peut-être fou c5 est plus fort
pascal adam a pas de case obligé d'aller
en f1
kovalev 5 peut-être fou c5 et là je
contrôle tout ça la tour attaque lada il
peut pas mettre de pièces devant la dame
parce qu'en plus il ya la menace de
gagner à une pièce par ok par des 4
pas oublier qu'en plus j'ai ma batterie
tour dames là qui menacent de faire
matin ses deux dès que j'aurai joué à
quatre là ça va pas tarder de 3oh 3
3 x 3 x 3 on peut jouer
fouet
je sais j'ai l'air
sion sagan au moins une pièce
d4 et on a gagné au moins une pièce et
c'est pas fini
ça va jouer avec les six pas de risque
du pion sans doute
et là on veut jouer
5-4
oh non
ce pas au ray
hop
je suis juste en face
allez prise
l'homme prend
quelle est cette
c'est dommage j'avais le match direct à
nos 7 c'est pas grave
mais toujours très bien
voilà on va prendre des années archi
gagnant ok on a eu chaud parce que j'ai
cru que j'allais me faire mater
heureusement carreaux et fuite
je crois que je vous lève 6 mais j'ai
oublié que le fou clouer le pion s est
bon mais sinon il y avait trop de
puissance des noirs et ça a tenu sans
problème ok belle partie très très belle
oui la peur de rien et c'est vrai qu'il
a pris énormément de risques mais bon
c'est intéressant il a tout joué pour
l'attack et la fine
ma fille il a failli me
[Musique]
me piéger
sur la fin mais ça marchait pas
j'avais oublié que le fougueux clouer le
pion et donc j'étais pas loin de perdre
allez on joue face à alix 1298 je perds
c'est pas parce que c'est pas non c'est
pas mon style
et surtout je suis pas du tout bon donc
je suis trop de prise de temps a vu tout
à l'heure j'étais pas loin de tomber
or ou f4 aujourd'hui des 5
pendant l'été je voulais que six
2 6
un pion non
les premiers pions
c'est toujours ça de près de prix sheikh
n'empêchait projet à l'échec
qui
on sait jouer damas 3 sort de se rendre
peu de là quand même
e
comme 17
où je fasse attention
palais daming d'un destin mais c'est
peut-être d'en prendre
un masque
qui
et si je crois
ce
sortir le fouet à six sont dans une
bonne idée
mt 4
ok allez on prend
ces cinq prises prise prise de calais
prend pas trop
moi j'ai comme le faire
pour éviter de me retrouver andy
et
avec mes clients qui seraient attaqués
par l'adversaire ou là donc ça s'est
très bien passé
ouais on va prendre ça
voici ce
aux cavaliers aux 50 km
17 tout de suite n'ont pas joué d'abord
tour on sait 8
la lesbienne option
ok donc là on va sortir le roi là je
pense pour activer notre tour il faut
absolument que je vous avais toutes les
pièces aux échecs
voilà donc là c'est bon mais je tombais
vite
on active la colonne
évidemment je recule parce que je lâche
pas la colonne le pas lui donner la
colonne ou la tour prends tout reprend
ça sert pas ça me permet
mettre le câble et le 4
c'est rare ya ce coup parce qu'ils
tapent sur un mur ici
jouer avec tours b 2 on attaque
f2 et puis on est pas loin d'aller à
dame aussi
oula alors là il ya cavaliers et prend
tout simplement attaque la tour et le
fou
échec
on va jouer avec ça les d4 de manière à
pouvoir asséné le mat ici
la jeune fille fait échec qui a on va
prendre tout simplement
parce qu'on veut voilà le faire échec
là le roi est coincé puisque le cavalier
protège
et c'est matt par fou prend effondrement
donc lâché trop de pions je fais mon
début quand même il on est peut-être pu
faire mieux mais on a réussi on se
retrouve bien encore on et 71 71 joueurs
ben écoutez c'est pas mal
c'est bien même très bien
c'est le deuxième meilleur score du
tournoi après celui de la semaine
dernière où on est et 79 que des flyers
c'est fatigant nous dit usb
supérieur at
ah ah
bon alors il n'y a pas trop de flag
heures en 3 + 2 parce que si on joue un
peu vite on peut pas tomber
donc c'est vrai que c'est plus dur
normalement on doit pouvoir justement
avec le 3 + 2 avec le plus de on peut on
doit pouvoir tenir le plupart du temps
allez on va jouer face à fish se5
5 lyon joue les qualifs 3
donc je me méfie parce que 1ère fois je
me suis fait planter un truc ou c4
khalef 6 on va jouer que les g5
il
check
il revient
systalians 3
le coût de l'est de nice
coup les nits qu'ayyash 3
alors
détroit
câble et c6 intéressant
ce que les chiens
puisqu'il n'a pas pris en france 3
maintenant je ramène en fait l'idée
c'est que je vais mettre le cavaly là
sans que le sang coule et noir jouent
quatre ce qui est le coup un peu
standard dans cette position en fait
ou c'est pas c'est pas du tout pareil
[Musique]
alors on peut jouer qu'est ce qu'on va
jouer là
bon je te lèves 3
non
f3 très bien notre france 3 je pense
cet échec ici ça peut pas
or de mal
ouais c'est ça c'est une réussite 1
va faire n'ont peut-être pas là parce
qu'il va jouer fuji 4 1
jouer avec h3
comme cette web
comme à 2
comme ces sept fous
twelve 3
du 7
tire aucun
d'âme des uns
j'ai cinq hockey
donc c'est pas mal
trois des fois on peut venir là si le
fou 17 bouger puis on peut aussi venir
ici
angers7
quatre ans semble bien
eh bien
homme des deux bien
et on fait un tour cela doit être pas
mal
essayer d'échanger maximum de matériel
j'ai un pion de plus
quand même l'idée
j'ai 4 1 a logiquement n'y a pas le
choix faut prendre de toute façon
ok
il faut prendre
jouer
j'ai 3
parce que sinon il menacé de venir en
âge de faire au match mais on n'a pas
envie on n'a pas envie de se faire mater
après la question savoir est-ce que
c'est mon droit qui est moins bien
protégée où le sien il semblerait bien
que ce soit le sien d'accord ou pas
il ya une chaîne youtube diagonale télé
et me nos échecs quelle est la
différence
différence c'est sur la chaîne diagonale
tv il ya que les vidéos diagonale tv
alors sur la chaîne i mean aux échecs il
ya aussi d'autres
d'autres vies
des vidéos qui sont pas de diagonale tv
sont essentiellement ça la différence
alors tour
là tu sembles utilisiez
ouais faut faire tort quatre ici
[Musique]
key
5 on va doubler
c est pourquoi je pas fait
check
d'accord
vocifère dame f4
aussi faire tour cette hausse était bien
à damas où la dame de fer en ses 6
peu embêtant quand même
et aussi d'en prendre si on prend d'un
échec
ça va bien je fais 2004 35 secondes
contre 49 il faut que
donc je joue aussi lentement
là l'idée c'est de jouer très solide 1
ok donc là
tours sète qui menace
à lesquelles aider si ça
pas terrible eh oui
il l'a vu malheureusement je me suis
planté
et malheureusement je lui ai donné
or je lui donne tout oh la la
trop tranquille dans cette partie je
suis complètement déconcentrer
j'ai demandé deux pièces directement
ah la la
quelqu'un passe
enfin
quelqu'un tu as trois ans
partie bravo à bravo à lui
non
il a réussi à tenir jusqu'au bout on et
71 71
on n'est qu'à 8 8 joueurs du record
c'est pas mal un petit tour non à 71
assez bien
allez c'est parti on joue face à un +13
ali tac tac tac
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
on va jouer livre on repart sur e4
d'accord merci à peu va falloir checker
les deux chaînes alors je me souviens
démissionner monatélé qui était top puis
j'ai fait une pause et chicken ah bah
ouais il faut reprendre
c'est le confinement il faut des
consignes et fodé confiner le jeu
d'échecs qu'avait laissé trois quais les
psys salle et on va jouer avec g3
fou j'ai 2
cabello 2
place fer forgé de 4 ou pas ouais je
vais faire petit rock
détroit est logique
dors b1 est logique
[Musique]
à 5
que 5 5e
il faut 3
[Musique]
caillaud 6
alors ce caillou 6 j'ai envie de faire f
j'ai aussi envie de faire cavaler des 5
un bébé 5 aussi
le sac est pas mal non parce qu'il peut
aussi pour tak tak
non on ne peut pas
le trouve je profite du fait qu'il ait
joué à cinq qui peut être s'avérer
affaiblissant ici parce qu'il a il a il
a affaibli cette classe donc j'ai mis
mon cavalier et ses cavaliers y
contrôler la casse des 4 donc tout est
maintenant peut-être je peux pousser
décati fait rien
[Musique]
de ce qu'il fait
calais b 4
alors on tout prendre
ok
et maintenant probablement
c'est un foot des deux jeux c'est pas
fou des deux roues des deux c'est bien
ou 5
alors est-ce qu'on tombait 4 ouais ça
doit être pas mal hein
p4
[Musique]
alors f5
pourquoi je laisse faire acheter à tous
pensent
joseph 4 ici sans doute voilà
si joseph 4 quand même ça me met un peu
la pression sur l'euro 1
envie
maintenant s'il prend mais sur tout
rendu fou pour pas laisser mon fou
enfermé ça c'est sûr
2 6 1
pour les 5e hockey
donc là on peut
il faut faire une idée
ces cinq c'est un peu l'idée 1 je pense
maintenant c'est la classe des six que
je vise
en plus ça affaiblit un peu le pion aux
absurde
dans quatre prisons reprend me sur
tranquillement
prise en le cas
on prend l'air pas mal façons il faut
prendre il faut il faut faire comprendre
pas trop trop le choix
alors fou un fou de 5
qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya des menaces 3
qui
cible il ya aussi fou prend d'en prendre
un b3 qui change les dom
qui me semble un peu pas très bon donc
je fais d'hommes dame f3 koller meilleur
la prise je reprends
prise au quai
donc la chute est brutale et des six
qui check
si on prend ça et vite ça évite d'un
match 4
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de danger celle non plus
ouh là alors
peu
en 17
dans
s'y prend
honte
oula
c'est possible on veut jouer fouet ce
cas peut-être
c'est compliqué pour les noirs parce
qu'il y avait les 17 qui menace la
s'attaque ici
alors on prend un possible d'un cran est
possible aussi
leurs gagnants tout de suite
si on prend
- 9 secondes qui est prise en reprend et
dames simone ok merci à + 13 mai le
parti
il reste 20 minutes
c'est tendu et finalement c'est quand
même
récent et 74 on est à cinq joueurs prêts
aux records
dx r2i wei foo checker les deux chaînes
ouais ok les deux chaînes alors des 4
d-4d cadre des quatre cavaliers m6
ces quatre je vais pas refaire mon truc
de tout à l'heure ça m'avait parce
réussit donc je vais faire g6
où j'ai sept
allez petit rock
où
ces cinq chiffres
des six
aussi sans doute
prise
pour se présenter
beaucoup beaucoup coupon de 8
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut faire peut-être fou j'ai
quatre noms f5 peut-être
pas si nice non
cavalia si si si
vous êtes 5
où ce ne fut pas suivant
prendre pour prendre fou des trains ne
plaît pas des masses on va faire
cavalier à 6
l'essai 7
alors fou 17 ou
parce qu'on fait à six
e
dès sa touche
celle où j'ai 4 h trois groupes rosneft
trois faux prince parce que c'est bien
ça rassure
quel est le cas pour libérer un peu mon
fou g7
les faire céder 7 d'abord
blanc continue 1 - 3
on va faire caler à cissé cavale et b4
non
calais g4 est possible
menace
cavalier 3 on aimerait bien éliminer ce
fou en ce retrait content parce que
notre ou g7 il va rigoler il va être
très content
quel dehors l'on peut pas parce que la
torah 3
on compte pas
ouais
alors on va jouer pts 5
donc déjà ça bloque toute idée de jouer
et c'est laisse à contrôler la case de
quatre concept cars 2 4 peut-être un
jour j'ai envie d'y mettre mon travail
est là
partie compliquée
donc demain je ferai un nouveau stream
en direct sur une mini aux échecs
ouais sans doute parce que j'ai vu qu'il
ya un beau tournoi à le tourner en effet
feu du soir mais je pense que je vais
pas jouer le soir parce que je vais très
fatigué j'ai des choses à faire et mais
je jouerai sans doute qu'alexis je
jouerai sans doute donc vers 17 heures
je crois
comment vous serez mis au courant sans
doute
quelques noms joue à six
emeterio 4
[Musique]
3 h 2
lord à 9,6
tours sète tours 8 est-ce que je peux
doubler les pièces comme ça ça m'a l'air
possible
ça m'a l'air possible
kbc 3
il faut laisser probable s'il prend 1,4
reprend il ya des problèmes donc je vais
faire tours 7
bonjour
cavalier cas pas de super case le palais
h katia la dame s'il vient de d2 je peux
peut-être poussé le 3
voilà est obligé d'aller là
c'est pas la fête
et pas la fête on va doubler
menaces de pousser ici
commence à sentir un peu le roussi là
pour les pour les blancs cette position
il faut pas jouer cinq ici
t'es pas un contre
dommage qu'un truc pas mal je
ouais h4h cas très bien où le j4 ou
est très risqué ça
d4
2006 aussi à ma passé mon fou devant la
dame
le temps j'ai complètement oublié la
tombe gul
ça m'a repris ohlala
et à ce que j'ai fait ici
[Musique]
j'avais tellement une position
intéressante que j'ai complètement
oublié de regarder
et du coup je perds 3 0 face à filtrer
ce sont 18 là ça va pas
suis complètement relâché n'est pas du
tout regardé la pendule du tout pas une
fois de la partie je crois
évidemment bits ça pardonne pas regardez
pas la pendule c'est sûr que ça aide pas
assez dommage on avait une très très
bonne position
et
la travailler mais bon
allez ça fait partie du jeu allez on
joue fast arous terre allez il faut
jouer 4 on a encore le temps d'en faire
deux peut-être trois dans le meilleur
des cas kf3
allez on fait face qu'à trouver 5 allait
pousser 4
ghanem johnny une jolie tout à l'heure
la halle et un beau jolie gambie evans
avec bébé avec bécade pardon c'est 3
allée des 4
attention comme bill owens
alors d'un b3 tout de suite
si rock
pas ou que les 6
ou à trois
d
ouais ouais ouais ouais
la malaisie 4
on prend
que va les prendre
là il faut faire attention
ils menacent échec celui de d'emprunt
quel et 2
au cices
damas quatre échecs
deux cas peut-être
avec un lieu 4 c'est très compliqué là
très compliqué
[Musique]
aulas ou quoi ça mène
waouh
[Musique]
c'est costaud
ballon
peut-être fou b5
partie toujours très complexe ici
il ya de quoi en perdre son latin
un tour
en c1 l'idée c'est qu'on est en face et
que quand on est en face il peut se
passer des trucs
alors
pas mal hein ce qu'il a fait là
prendre on prend ça va pas aller prendre
[Musique]
que les prends ça donne bien
non
rend ici
et à la fin on prend là
détroit ok
l'homme prend 1,7
faire échec à ramasser la tour
tour d un allez on fait tourner un
on va faire d'hommes d'amd 4
et ce prise ok donc tour 2 trop deux
tours de il faut faire
il faut faire c'est pas clair
toro 2 c'est pas facile
on ici
pour prendre
et à la fin on a un qui en plus c'est
tout un ajustement de plus ce qui est un
tout petit peu léger
allez on va jouer quatre vingt dix le
roi
on opte très vite faire ça
tg
monte
prends ici
autre
3 6
on monte le roi
or ici on va descendre le roi
je voulais j'ai 3
je peux pas monter le roi
tous ces
c'est encore
on va avancer
c'est
m
cake
le faire nul ça non
ça devrait faire nul
entre pop
-plus
46 ouais
ok
ok nul bravo du coup ça m'a pas permis
de rester collé un
cette défaite tout à l'heure
un nul au même si j'avais gagné salins
de toute façon j'étais
un peu lâché pour le podium donc ce
qu'ils sont bien partis pour le podium
il reste deux minutes il reste 6 kills
calmes
loïc fournier est pas pas le tueur par
le tueur
le tueur un pseudo à 2,6 fin attention
au temps ouais un ton email ouais bah
oui
hier aux nerfs 13 daiwei times
trop tard
là j'ai pas très bien joué la finale jeu
mais bon c'est façon c'était
sur la fin mon salon on pourra pas la
finir dans le tournoi donc on va juste
essayer de bien la jouer pour finir
le sens de finir bien
des 5 parce que là le ton sera fini
avant et donc ça comptera pas on va
prendre
des six des quatre on va jouer cavalier
avec à 6
[Musique]
roger 4
ce
le
travail au sein qu'il faut prendre
p5 sans doute
calais 17 noms
ouais ok les 17
mieux
bizarre ça je prends le pion
ou f4 dames c'est celle que je tiens le
pion
je crois que c'est tromper
on s'est vite
ces 5
et 5 x 4
ces cinq points 4
ça va ok je devrais être peut-être mais
je suis pas inquiet
ok donc leur fausse 89,5 attaqué à taxer
courage
se passer plein de trucs là
je sais pas si je me lasse pas g5 là
d'ailleurs
5 ce qui fait qu'il peut jouer dame b
cette attaque le fou ici donc si je
prends l'âge perçu là c'est pas clair
donc c'est pas j'ai peut-être pas
laisser faire ça
jouer aux dés 8 autour des 8
de 8,3 des 8
c'est le piège ça
[Musique]
pas du tout pensé à ça et c'est un peu
de temps
tout reprendre tout reprendre sa marche
pas
[Musique]
pas du tout pensé à ça
comme j'ai 6
pour prendre tout reprendre bahia mais
pas d'échec intermédiaire
je me sors ça
prendre ici le pion sans doute
[Musique]
pas du tout vu ce piège là dedans
à main bien vu
alors besoin de rien envie de toi on
conseille pour mieux placer le pièce
mineurs dans les partis ebay ne faut pas
qu'ils se marchent dessus
donc l'idée c'est de d'essayer de voir
d'abord la case où vous voulez la m
alors tu peux prendre
[Musique]
en
tom pépin
donc on va jouer
4e voire une autre
[Musique]
ok
allez
on rentre là dedans parce que je vois
rien d'autre
pourquoi de réfléchir à pourquoi
je commande un second temps pour y
réfléchir
je crois que là il a gaffé
pas vu l'attaqué finale ici il a cru
qu'il pouvait prendre 26
mais là le problème c'est que j'attaque
la dame et en plus je menace une
découverte
il propose là dessus mais non pas pour
annuler la maintenant que je suis
gagnant
ok on va
enfin je prends et c'est moi qui ai une
qualité de plus
qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour ce 8
le laisse prendre ici
kate 5
non
prise
hop
aux 4
ben ali c'est bon ça va gagner
facilement là maintenant
le plus dur je passe a été fait
bon faut pas vendre la peau de l'ours
mais ça commence à sentir bon le
fin
attention temps on va
juste aller chercher
t
ok
[Musique]
échec
c'est tout simplement
et devra abandonner je pense ici échec
on pousse on fait d'hommes
pas de ne pas ton peut pas flag est ici
ce qu'il n'a pas il n'a pas saisi le
truc
check
ok merci à pas le tueur bon fini sur une
bonne note mais c'est une partie hors
tournoi donc bon c'est pas grave je
pense qu'on a fait un bon tournoi à
l'ensemble alors bravo à loïc fournier
est superbe
bravo la peau dit l'autre fournier qui
fait une perf à 2271
et qui avait joué 20 parties
qui a fait quelques berset quand même
pour un 20 % de père sec deuxième ce
qu'il calme qui fait une belle perf à
alors qu'il est un héros à 2368 donc ok
c'est superbe
avec quatorze partis un peu moins pas le
tueur qui fait une perf à 2327 et 17
parties jouées
donc il a mis il ya pas mal aussi donc
ça c'est le podium bravo au podium
alors ensuite à kormann fitch est ce qui
nous qui nous mène au score ils mènent
au score la 3 0 ça va dommage il va
falloir régler ça un jour donc alors on
fait une perf voilà qui est correct
quand même 1 2285 16 parties jouées
toute personne qui on a un peu lâché sur
la fin c'est un peu déconcentré dans une
position où on avait largement de quoi
de quoi faire et on a fini sur une bonne
note je trouve une bonne partie
intéressante ensuite usb
hurle rares ou la canne a perdu pas mal
là mais qui fait une perf en 1934 il
fait un bon tournoi gnl chess qui fait
une petite paire par rapport à son
classement
rooster qui fait un bon tournoi ensuite
on à mathias robben strasser bel
strasser qui souffrent on mène 9 à 2
face à lui
il va il va sûr qu'il va préparer
quelque chose pour la prochaine fois
puisqu'il est souvent ici blitzer king
aussi on mène 80 face habite sur king
max writer y avait des nouveaux joueurs
aussi s'il ya et je me dis qu'on a dû
jouer la première fois donc bomou 68 qui
avec avait gagné le tournoi de samedi
dernier mme oumou 68 et donc il fait une
petite perf aujourd'hui était en petite
forme un 1969
ensuite on à mg 17 08 17 qui fait une
perf à 1907 on à robson diagne qui fait
en 1890 barrichello à 1928
alors je vais pas tous les citer là
allez une petite un petit banc pour
hervé 66 qui est un habitué qui fait a
encore une bonne perf à pourvoir mai 68
décidément la russe 26 qui progresse il
fait une perf à 1825 ce qui est très
bien ce qui monte c'est au-dessus de son
lots
malgré voyez qu'il en a quand même perdu
pas mal mais le niveau du tournoi et qui
était quand même assez fort
aujourd'hui le petit dragon qui a joué
sur la fin il a bercé qui est pas mal
apparemment
et puis saluons aussi que ce que ceux
qui sont venus jouer la foule 14e' ajami
harmonique et socra monique et ce au
jambon et fromage
c'est ce qu'ont fait quelques parties
il y en a encore qui sont inscrits me
compare à jouer d'accord ok et leur truc
on peut se connecter à temps
où il était pris par autre chose et puis
voilà bon bien sûr tout le monde n'a pas
joué toutes les parties puisque mais sur
belle aprilia
parfois des impératifs mais en tout cas
et pas mal de coûter c'était pas mal
c'était vraiment un tournoi super tout
cas je me suis amusé à vos travaux
podium
donc donc rendez vous rendez vous
bientôt
alors si vous avez envie de jouer
écoutez il est 22h40 de si vous voulez
jouer un ou deux litres avec moi je vais
vous proposer un 3 2
de ariane au godo master qui nous dit
merci de tv super comme tournoi plus
bravo à tous voilà bon je crois que
c'est bien c'est si bien c'est bien
ou sur la corde sensible en effet
passeport savoir-faire en plein d'âme
est parti j'ai parfois du mal aussi
bravo merci super intéressant de l'oif
joubaud merci donc demain ça sera
je vais sans doute je vais stream et
donc sans doute vers 17h ou 18h bonne
façon je joue le jeu posterai le si vous
êtes abonnés si vous mettez l'abonnement
là sur youtube et que vous mettez la
petite cloche là vous serez prévenu que
le direct une heure avant le direct vous
serez prévenus qui en direct je peux
aller faire un tour d'ailleurs c'est ce
que j'ai envie de jouer demain
c'est demain voilà je le fais en a un
calendrier de tournois de leech s
alors demain il ya un truc qui
m'intéresse voilà c'est la reine bleach
je crois wendel r'n'b
trois heures les 5 0
voilà j'ai plutôt envie de faire ça
parce que je pars me couchais tard
demain et il ya un vide ça fait feu mais
bon je l' ai déjà fait trois fois je
vais peut-être pas le faire demain
bon c'est pas encore totalement décidé
mais a priori c'est ça que c'est ça je
vais faire donc je jouerai à partir de
17h demain sans doute et c'est toujours
ce que je ferai sur une mine aux échecs
voilà
donc oubliez pas que vous avez le
le aussi le petit
voilà le petit le petit sondage
je vous remets le sondage dans le dans
le chat si vous êtes toujours là et puis
voilà il ya toujours 56 votes 1 c'est
pas mal un bon c'est clairement le 3 + 2
1 qui plaît un bon que ça veut dire qu
on se rejoint là dessus cc c'est sa
basse à bas tous les autres c'est 48%
contre 25% sur le 5 + 3
donc quand même scène post rock est pas
mal aussi mais pour que le cercle 3 soit
intéressant il faut pas jouer deux
heures il faut jouer trois heures parce
que sinon on n'en fait pas assez
c'est les parties plus lente
je ferai d'autres sondages comme ça pour
pouvoir
notamment
savoir si vous avez envie de faire des
les sessions ne peux plus je dirais un
peu plus
les sessions un peu plus pédagogique ou
je ne sais quoi tiens voilà donc aller
loïc fournier qui veut à prendre sa
revanche
allez l'onu fournier attention c'est un
bon joueur 1 2334
allez on va jouer que quatre
c'est un cas les c4
bien parce que ça sort des schémas
pourquoi jouer autre chose en jouant
mais
bon je sais jouer autre chose bien sûr
c'est juste que sam ça me convient
ah les qualifs 6 allez petit rock
j'avais des droits
le 5 ok tombé 1
où j'ai 4 ans jouer car
là on doit pouvoir jouer aux quatre noms
4 x 100
ouais ça va être pas mal
4 alors là il ya deux écoles soit
non il faut jouer les quatre sessions
et quatrième sets
je prends du cavalier sans doute et ça
attaque le fou donc je récupérerai se
fout je pense
pas sûr
aussi prendre de fou
pour moi qui apprend le principe de base
c'est trop rapide oui oui sans doute si
vous êtes débutant c'est vrai que le 3 +
2 c'est ça fait un peu peur
j'ai besoin de dix secondes parcours
ouais ok
alors qu'elle les projecteurs
f5 prise prise en
ce qu'il faut faire et s'est incliné
moi j'habite sur f5 alors je peux
prendre à f/5 ou un g4
m
voilà l'idée maintenant c'est de faire
ça avec l'idée que je contrôle la case
f5
parce que
contrôler presque presque lacazette 5
calais des cinq ici
il
la bise
on échange ça
qui fait aimer sûr je prends donc j'ai
fait ça pour pour éviter de me prendre
la taxe sur le roi
essayer de valoriser ma pièce de plus
simplement
f5 on va prendre
évidemment qu'on prend
et là on peut prendre g41
voilà je crois que les dents sont foutus
voilà
merci à loïc fournier
[Musique]
ok de fans revanche beaucoup
arrêtez là donc les 22h49
loïc
c'est loïc a gagné non le tournoi
vérifie
merci loïc le têt arrêter la joute oui
mais oui c'est logique
ben on finit bien du coup un joueur à
terre du coup ça finit bien ce qu'il
prendra sa revanche la prochaine fois
comme ça il aura envie de revenir
bravo loïc fournier en tout cas pour
cette superbe victoire
donc qu'est ce que je voulais dire
d'autre
[Musique]
c'est tout je ferai peut-être un autre
sondage pour le mardi soir c'est bien ça
marche bien à savoir aussi si je vais si
je veille à un moment aussi qu'il veut
jouer 68
si je vais faire un sondage pour savoir
pour le samedi je sais pas si le samedi
ça vous va comme tournoi je sais pas il
ya beaucoup 68 qui veut jouer
alors est-ce qu'on finit par ça
12h50
épuisée là je suis bien amusé donc je
vais je vais arrêter là merci merci
merci pour le pour le tournoi merci pour
le pour le dialogue aussi
c'est stanton kochoyan variations la
sicilienne avec ses 4 d'accord ok
bon moi j'ai joué ça j'ai vu juste que
ça m'a évité de connaître trop de trop
de trucs ne sont pas trop mal dans le ce
système bon il faut que je puisse tout
autre chose
je varie voilà ok
allez on va arrêter là je vous dit ciao
ciao ont pesé vous bien
et puis on se voit demain si vous voulez
partir de 17h certainement donc et puis
et puis sinon se verra peut-être samedi
je vais voir si je fais une tournée
samedi aussi ok allez ciao ciao